هي اكبر مدينه في شبه جزيره القرم وهي
موقع
استراتيجي يكتسب اهميه كبيره حيث تعد
قاعده لاسطول البحر الاسود الروسي في
يناير اكد الرئيس الاوكراني فولودي ميرسي
تعهده باستعاده شبه جزيره القرم التي
تسيطر عليها روسيا وقال للمنتدى الاقتصادي
العالمي في دافوس
اراضينا لكن رغم اصرار اوكرانيا على
مهاجمه شبه جزيره القرم يقف في الدعم
الاكبر لها في الحرب مترددا نتحدث عن
الولايات المتحده في اتصال هاتفي لم يتم
بثه بين وزير الخارجيه الامريكي ومجموعه
من الخبراء يوم امس قال رئيس الدبلوماسيه
الامريكيه ان اي محاوله لاستعاده شبه
جزيره القرم ستكون خطا احمر بالنسبه
الامر الذي ينذر باستجابه روسيه اوسع حسب
بوليتيكو فان تصريح بلينكن كان ردا على
سؤال حول امكانيه
مساعده امريكا لاوكرانيا من اجل تحقيق
هدفها الطويل الاجل وهو استعاده الاراضي
التي سيطرت عليها روسيا بلينكن لم يتوقف
عند هذا الحد بل قال ان الولايات المتحده
لا تشجع اوكرانيا على استعاده شبه جزيره
القرم لكن القرار يرجع الى كيف احدها يؤكد
ان التركيز الامريكي الان ايضا هو يهدف
لمساعده اوكرانيا على ان التقدم في
المناطق التي يتركز فيها القتال كشرق مثلا
[موسيقى]
لم يبتعد بلينك كثيرا عما قاله مسؤولون
كبار في البنتا لاعضاء لجنه القوات
المسلحه في مجلس النواب قبل اسبوعين حيث
اكدوا انهم لا يعتقدون ان اوكرانيا يمكن
ان تستعيد شبه جزيره القرم في المستقبل
القريب ويعتبر الامريكيون ان امرا كهذا قد
يستفز ردا من بوتين الذي يرى ان شبه جزيره
القرم هي جزء من روسيا وان الاوكرانيين
استفادوا من خطا الاتحاد السوفيتي حيث نقل
الاتحاد السوفيتي اداره القرم الى جمهوريه
اوكرانيا التابعه له عام 1954 ثم مع
استقلال اوكرانيا عام 1991 استقلت القرن
كجزء من اوكرانيا وهو ما يراه بوتين خطا
يتم تصحيحه مع ضم القرم عام 2014 حتى اكثر
الامريكيين تفاؤلا بشان مستقبل القرم رئيس
الاركان مارت ميلي قال ان استعاده
اوكرانيا للقرن يمكن ان يحدث ولكنه صعب
للغايه
المهمه العسكريه الخاصه بطرد الروسي من كل
اوكرانيا صعبه جدا ولن تحدث خلال اسبوعين
الا اذا انهار الجيش الروسي باكمله وهو
امر مستبعد لذا من باب الاحتمالات احتماله
ان يحقق الجيش الاوكراني النصر الكامل
بمعنى تربروس من كل اوكرانيا بما في ذلك
شبه جزيره القرم احتماليه حدوث ذلك عسكريا
في اي وقت قريب هي احتماليه بعيده
لكن ما هي الاسباب شبه جزيره القرم عباره
عن ثكنه عسكريه ضخمه مليئه بالدفاعات
الجويه ومخازن الذخيره والعشرات الالاف من
القوات توجد مئات الخنادق والمواقع
المحصنه التي تمتد الى مئات الكيلومترات
يقول خبراء امريكيون انه من الصعب على
القوات الاوكرانيه اختراق هذه الخطوط
الروسيه حتى مع استمرار الدعم العسكري
السخي من الغرب ثم ان امريكا ايضا لم تسلم
اوكرانيا اسلحه تمكنها من مهاجمه القرن
فمثلا تطالب اوكرانيا بصواريخ التاكس التي
يصل مداها الى 300 كيلو متر ليبلغ او يبلغ
مسؤولون في البانتاجون ممثليكي بانه لا
يوجد لدى الولايات المتحده فائض من هذه
الانظمه الصاروخيات التكتيكيه حتى تزود
اوكرانيا بها وهو رد يجنب امريكا ربما حرج
اعلان تخوفها من رد الفعل الروسي على خطوه
كهذه
[موسيقى]